hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to party hard tycoon now if
you remember party hard it was a game
about trying to murder everybody in a
party so now there's a tycoon version of
the game I have no idea what that means
but I'm gonna give it a go oh hi oh you
can fast forward the calendar of the
days long sure you can only throw one
party portal today there are five
different grades I'm gonna go to squat
ah then you preview sure choose a theme
we'll eat me of course it's gonna be a
food fest for charity Oh lovely my
person now alright I got ninja Brian
over here and Count Dracula sure
entrance fee
well it's charity so we got to get
something do not forget to check the
grade to the party when managing a mark
who your visitors how does that work
more it costs more means more visitors
fear let's start the party then hi hello
I don't know what's happening ah yes
let's get the tunes bouncing over here
but that's the broken-down cars yes sure
I like this oh yeah
let's get them bumping over enjoy your
dream maybe over here right by the tub
you get it right there oh yeah so people
can dance on that lovely picnic blanket
I think sure lighting projector I don't
know what the bar means but sure yes
smoke cannon love it get those smoke
cannons a blowin sure start this party I
have no high
hello hi ninja Brian you're looking
lovely today
go Count Dracula go oh hi there is no
free table what does free tables mean
what do I was dude you didn't give me a
tutorial or nothing oh boy I'm not
people aren't happy I don't know what a
free table is do not forget to engage
your personnel they boost your party
okay how do I do that
things seem to be cut off on the bottom
hang on wait hang on everybody stop
everybody stop everybody stop everybody
get out get the out get out get the
out okay I have no idea what the
happened
I made some profit apparently it's not
profit if my investment was forty five
hundred my income was 126 I didn't
exactly make a lot of money all right
we're gonna do this again and this time
I'm actually going to think about what
I'm doing and I'm gonna read we're gonna
go cocktail Knights now give me a beer
now cocktails because it's slightly in
un dhis and i like it being a little in
un de s-- Oh tables okay we're gonna get
we're gonna make it cheaper four dollars
or it all it seems fine and it should be
free entrance free is fee is free
yeah that's it's free it's gonna be free
that's what's gonna be great about this
oh ah table I see okay I think I'm
starting to understand what this is all
about oh yeah you guys are gonna be
blasted with the music here oh you are
going to love it oh yeah let's get some
old let's get a barbecue going oh hell
yeah over in the bad area everyone loves
having a barbecue in the bad area uh
let's get a large table over here oh
yeah brah decor ah let's focus on
getting more music up in this and hairy
up you can't do that not enough power
one speaker for this table yeah I think
we're gonna like that oh I think we're
gonna like that alright let's go for it
now the party can start let's go do it
let's do it let's do it oh hi hello
don't worry about it it's free get in
there
party your hats off hey go on in have a
good time
hey you have a good time in there
alright cool you guys having fun great
you guys go ahead
oh yeah ninja Brian oh you get it okay
everyone's unhappy why why are you
unhappy I don't know what he's doing
there we go jeezum why do I even have
you around here if you're not gonna do
anything light oh oh it is lit oh it is
lit there no one here wait where's you
what happy it's cocktails night start a
show right here get it on ninja Brian
get it on oh oh hell yeah oh uh Count
Dracula get get the out of the way
serve food everywhere ah that's what we
needed
all right we got Macho Man Randy Savage
as the only guest at this party we have
done up somewhere we have
up yep I invited two people feel like it
lost a lot of money there lost a lot of
money on that one but you know early
start here early start ooh my house well
that's better
oh let's just do that oh let's get a
beer fest going on lots of food and
fights hell yeah love it alright we're
gonna I need to make some money so let's
do this with a lot of entrance
fee alright everybody hold on to your
dicks spear barrel we're gonna need a
beer barrel that's like a must
we're gonna have one
there we're gonna have one there we're
going to have one in that room there
going to be one in that room there's
going to be a barbeque over in that room
there's going to be a small table
spitter spatter table labels here
they're everywhere
no one's going to be at a loss for table
space still not omnipresent sure about
this but you know what we're gonna go
for it all right now I'm feeling it yeah
let's get some music in here some tunes
hell yeah okay all right here some decor
ornamental cactus oh that is big
something for people to get impaled on
if they make mistakes
yeah that's good okay now we've got
something going on here so let's start
the party let's get people in here let's
just start I want I want I want it I
want everything get everything
everything everywhere do the things get
the food do the food get it get it going
you serve food here somewhere serve food
where I don't know what you're doing why
are you guys start a show start a show
okay I don't know what's happening I do
not know what's happening I think it's
working I think this party is working I
think everyone is super happy
[Music]
yeah okay I don't know yeah okay he did
something there he did something I don't
know why he did but he did something so
far so goo why are they all out there
why are you all out on the street what
are you doing over there boobs McKenzie
what do you doing out there you
cosplayers get in the party and get it
partying up I'm so cool you guys don't
understand how cool I am if you just
understand how cool I am it's just
getting my house and party with me have
a great time
why aren't you guys partying with me
bye did you did you have fun did you
enjoy holy I think I did good
people were disappointed but oh well too
hungry
14 expected more hype and fun than
whatever huh
spend all the money they had invited all
the people who was invited to your party
based on entrance fees and people who
are passing by and I made a little bit
of profit so I'm gonna consider that a
success yes I did it I did it I did it
up I did it up oh wow my up I like this
guy he reminds me of medicine and
therefore myself so I'm gonna go to this
guy oh hell yeah
we're gonna get the real carnival the
Carnivale I'll give you something cool
but funk Oh punk rock oh I got to go
carnie ball oh we're gonna be so
glamorous alright everything seems to be
locked so let's fast forward to the next
challenger day oh they're alright okay
we got some fans over there we got a lot
of equipment so what we need to do is we
need to make this a lot more hype Oh way
more hype so what we're going to do is
we're going to make this carnival dance
and have fun love is in the air Oh
indeed it is and only in BD do and I'm
gonna get him to pay a lot of money I
know they're gonna expect hype but I'm
about to bring the hype are you ready
for the hype from lighting projectors so
I got it like establish one room as the
dance room right
so one rooms got to be the dance room so
let me hang on so if I ok let's sell
some of these beer things and let's
assume that this needs to be more
centralized as in over there so we're
going to get rid of the decorative
cactus I hate to do that but you got to
do what you got to do all right
purple rug oh I hope it's shag oh my god
and people are gonna cut this rug so
hard oh that's good that's good oh yeah
oh no that's wrong okay
alright I think this is gonna be
something I don't know if it's gonna be
good but it's gonna be something so
let's get this party started
oh let's serve some drinks up in here
yes serve some food get some food go in
there oh yeah get the drinks where's the
drinks get the drinks where's the
goddamn drinks get the drinks at going
yeah it's the drinks go the drinks get
those drinks in there and go yeah yeah
yeah get the party started dance dance
dance dance dance start a show little
guy go over there and dance start a show
or a joke you start a show over here now
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
cirlewd cirlewd cirlewd serve food yes
yes yes every oh look at him go
oh yeah oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
sir food I think I don't know what
you're doing I don't even know if you're
valuable in any capacity but you know
it's a good enough for me
hell yeah hell yeah all of you losers
being outside like a bunch of losers are
just losers and I hate you you don't
deserve to be as party people as me
yeah let's start another show hell yeah
go go
he'll get out look at him go oh yeah
yeah yeah after another shell oh
yeah over here how about that good
they're losing it yeah I don't know
what's happening it I think my noises
are helping I think I have no idea okay
all right you know I think I think oh I
think we did it I think that was a good
party I think it was good party good guy
I think that was a good party I'm not
gonna lie
feel good about that one oh yeah we lost
fans but that's okay
hell yeah ah we're starting on we're
doing okay all right okay I'm gonna try
one more whoa tiny Club ooh I want an
actual club capacity whoo back in black
calls visitors to the show give some
likes and add 75% more height oh hello
of course I want that okay I'm gonna go
to the kind of club hang on I'm gonna go
over here I want to I sell my yeah
I don't know if it is actually gonna
help but I'm just trying to concentrate
things down I don't know if it's gonna
help at all
it probably won't but you know what I
can't know until you experiment okay you
start a show right here baby for this oh
hell yeah oh hell yeah Oh get the party
going
there we go that's what I'm talking
about
all right all right all right all right
okay so these things the trade things
are the things that people spend money
on and that's the only way that you can
get money out of people otherwise
they're just kind of done partying and
it only gets hype because of the
accessories that you have so I get it
now okay I'm understanding it I got a
little bit of understanding going on it
oh yeah oh yeah you guys are in for the
little show oh yeah oh yes so hype so hi
look how happy they were oh my god we
had 18 people thrilled with rube
18 people we got fans it worked it
concentrated it worked it worked I want
to throw in there but I just don't have
the money for it but I could just
concentrate it down you know what let's
try to do that no I couldn't afford
anything if I do that all right I've got
equipment here let me go here again and
then sell stuff and get that going
hopefully that'll be good lots of food
and fights no please okay let's make
this a lot more efficient now all right
everything is very centralized and also
I'm completely out of money did I
mention that I've not been smart with my
money here that's okay because this
party is going to get started and it is
going to be all the hook Oh get that
food in there yeah get ready for the
show baby oh yeah keep the show started
baby get it going on now oh yeah baby
dance the night away now oh yeah baby
start the show right now now oh yeah
baby everybody's mother each other oh
yeah baby get the hype going now oh yeah
baby my singing is really bad whoo yeah
baby it's empty I forgot about that one
hang on go but none of money okay never
mind I have it now Oh people are unhappy
why are they unhappy I have no idea
ye-yeah something tells me this one
isn't going as beautifully as the other
one was mmm okay I think we're people
happy I don't know we're people happy
this light show is awesome check my last
video from hashtag beer fest of funky I
like that I can't I like that damn it oh
[Music]
my people enjoyed it still made money
but I don't I didn't make any of my
investments oh frizzen party okay
party bikers cat I'll go a chat I'm Alma
Lenny all kind of I think I know what's
going on I think I know what I'm doing
wrong I think I think my problem is the
one like I'm learning a lot of other
game already whatever that's fine what I
need to do is I need to lower the fee
the entrance fee needs to be way lower
and I think that's important is that
although yeah I'm not gonna no entrance
fee at all none to start this party
straight up okay all right so you saw me
fail a whole bunch and that's totally
fine i was learning but now that I know
now that I'm kind of know what to do I'm
gonna start a new game because I spent
way too much money where I was not
supposed to spend money and I need to
get this party started because if I
don't do this party right then I'm not
going to do myself right and if there's
one thing the markiplier does its I do
myself right what the hell is this try
not to get kick ass at this race and
love will find you whoo people have some
fun than getting the best mood uh County
Madness with food and fight sure let's
go with that one I have no idea of god
these again alright so the
entrance fee is gonna be moderate I
don't know why why is that why does that
increase it you know what whatever I got
money like that so I'm gonna keep money
like that we're gonna get it bang it in
here and that it doesn't just what we're
gonna do hell yeah all right I've got
everything for an amazing party I've got
speakers boxing every
just blasting with sound I've got tables
I've got beer I've got everything I need
to make this party as great as it
possibly can be we've got so much hype
we've got so much booze is gonna be
great is the only thing I don't want is
this one here cuz that's just a waste so
what we need here we go coloured palm
that's what we need that's what I was
looking for right by the oh yeah that's
the kind of decorum that we need in here
because we need to pump up the height
but we don't eat wood heck heck ooh I
don't know how that works but ok don't
know how that works but apparently those
connected I think that's all for the
cheap stuff yeah all that stuff is
expensive I can't afford that
but it is going to begin laughs it's
going to be so let's you know let's get
another snow cannon in here cuz why not
why the Frick not there is no reason not
it is all yes oh yes oh that is good oh
that is good okay we are not leaving
here we have pumped out all the party
that we can we've taken all the power
we've gotten all the decor let me put
another stop sign over there just to
make it nice and linked up oh just stop
do not cross that line you the party is
over that way you don't need to go any
farther there's even other of a stop
sign on the wall over there you don't
need to go any farther the party is
already starting and you are late for it
so let's get this party started come on
let's do this oh yeah get it get it
mmm fill those tables up get people
drinking in their cups yeah okay things
see doodle doodle do I'll get it started
get it started here they come
oh I think those people are topless
great your oh girl Bloomberg Oh hmm do I
have to turn them on I have to turn them
on really I didn't know I had to do that
oh geez huh yeah huh yeah light it huh
light it up
yes this party is real good yeah I like
it
uh-huh okay cool let's do another round
of shots yay put the paw
lights on where did they go okay all
right I guess we're done with that now
how hype was that I was pretty good guys
you all would go that party right you'd
all go that party oh yeah you would you
know you would you know you would you
know you would of course you would why
wouldn't you why what a mess
all right so we the wave that is party
hard tycoon I'm not an expert at this
game I really am not uh it's kind of
hard to figure out because I don't
understand the mechanics hundred percent
but I was figuring it out and it was
kind of fun to be able to throw this
party so this game is not fully released
yet it is still just in like early
access phase I don't even know if it's
on seem right now but if it is I'll
pulling in the description if there's a
way for you guys to play it for yourself
to put a link in the description it's
pretty fun I I gotta admit even though
I'm a little confused and maybe I'm
doing it wrong which wouldn't be
surprised but either way thank you so
much for watching let me know how I did
in the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
[Music]